[Music]
okay it's Tom and Jenny we just got done
seeing what was it called Rimmel wall
fantastic piece the crimes yeah yes
Harry Potter pastes well yeah it's
actually a sequel to Grant astok beasts
and where to find them which which that
whole thing is like a prequel to the
Harry Potter stuff so it's like you got
Dumbledore young Dumbledore clay budgie
wha um you know you got all the [ __ ]
that's kind of referred to sometimes in
Harry Potter like his history and like
you know you kind of see it how that
kind of like you got to see you could
see like we're gonna get a broom and
show like that
yeah I'm just I was just a casual viewer
I've only seen one Harry Potter movie
else that's all the first one I didn't
really care for for its how you really
get into it the theater was packed full
of fans they reacted to it positively so
I think the movie will be successful it
had good it looked really good good
visuals acting was good mm-hmm
everybody that looks super cool oh he
depth his way through that whole [ __ ]
movie I'll tell you why he was actually
yeppity-do for somebody who doesn't
really give a [ __ ] about this franchise
he was kind of stole the show from me
whenever he was on screen it got a lot
more interesting the rest of it from the
point of view somebody's never written
these books and doesn't really care is
it there's a lot of characters you don't
know that they're important or not it's
a convoluted kind of story if you're not
familiar with what the hell's going on
and they're talking about stuff you have
no idea what the [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna say
I'm gonna recommend
that if you have not seen fantastic
beasts then if you see this you know
what I mean it's like I'd actually
didn't see fantastic beasts like I have
but I know the gist of what happened in
it and it's like I know enough about the
Harry Potter universe that like I
couldn't figure out what who everyone
was and like you know me like I
recognize all the last names and all
that kind of stuff
so but like I said this since it is a
sequel it's not one of those things
where it's like oh they standalone and
stuff like that you definitely have to
obtain fantastic because they refer a
lot to stuff that back then that
happened in that movie so um but other
than that like like I said you know if
you know what's going on it's you know a
lot more things like what the visual
effects was really cool yeah the nice
cool atmosphere like a lot of it was set
in Paris so it had like a lot of good
costumes
yeah like the costume design was really
good calling out what she's and it grabs
his daughter yeah so like I said you
know it's it's a good movie but you have
to have seen all the other ones which I
imagine is probably gonna be the case
because this is like a Harry Potter yeah
they were all into it so yeah so I mean
we saw it on its Monday for heaven's
sakes it was it was a bunch of people
and I'm just sitting there just put up
with it I'm watching like you know
pretty scenes and you know there's some
good action scenes and it start to start
with really strong weather you know
those guys escape from [ __ ] wizard
prison or whatever it it's dorky as hell
too okay if I just gotta just gotta go
there you know a minute I had I had a I
was constantly just shaking off the
feelings of cornball you know like yeah
they [ __ ] got magic wands and sit but
you know that's their thing if this is
your thing I'm sure you'll enjoy the
movie for me
no I'm not offended like you would ever
know it's like I said I mean I find all
the Harry Potter books and I saw our
movies so I knew enough about the
universe yet even though I didn't see
fantastic piece like I could still
follow it yeah but yeah for somebody
that doesn't know anything about it
you're not going to I was just basically
a different to it you had to have a
certain kind of [ __ ] cornball level
to enjoy it but hopefully I want to see
Cretu later this week all right so uh
that's all we can say about this movie
you
okay it's Tom and Jenny we're
we're DMC again we just saw one called
widows we were gonna go ahead and do the
review like we normally do inside but
it's just packed in there it's a
holidays it's Tuesday afternoon and I
guess a MC for stones members they have
$5 ticket Tuesdays and since it's a
holiday weekends you know Thanksgiving
we went to see widows it's like Twitter
what was it like 12:30 this 137 or 125
yeah full full like I think every seat
yeah we're sitting down the front
actually went too bad to sit down the
front okay what the movie was the movie
is a I guess he probably called an
underworld crime drama mixed with heist
movie and it's very long the director is
a British director named Steve McQueen
and it's not Stevens Queen you're
thinking about but anyway
it's about some gangsters think
evidently get killed during this heist
and their wives or their widows get
stuck with a bill this debt that they
have to repay so they found a way and a
bunch of records that from one of the
husbands way to make more money doing
another heist to kind of pay off the
dead alright
that's making a long story short
wouldn't you say yeah like a lot it's
interesting because the trailers for
this they're not really they're not
deceptive like they tell you that's
pretty much exactly what happens in the
movie but a lot of it is kind of like a
drama between the characters and like
there's a lot of kind of twists to it
and your politics involved yeah there's
like a whole subplot about like suppose
it's you know it's involved with the
heist that's going on in steps there's
like a lot of dirty dealings there and
then kind of like you're kind of seeing
like the relationship between the women
and you know how they'll find out
various things about how they're going
to do this because they're not you know
they're not
middles themselves like know how to do
any of this [ __ ] so actually I thought
it was really good it was like different
than what I was expecting
yeah but I liked it better than if it
had just been like a straight-up heist
kind of movie because like I said it's
got heist elements to it yeah and there
is it's you know it's got like a fight a
lot of violence and stuff but I actually
thought I just liked all the kind of
like underworld Chicago politics and all
this other kind of stuff that was going
on into the parallel and like I said
there's kind of big twice a market
spoiler yeah like that but um yeah it
was different than what I was expecting
but I liked it better than when I see a
crime movie it's got a hit on all the
points of a crime movie you know I mean
it's you know like Goodfellas was a good
one
you know Godfather all the classics you
know that's that's kind of that's kind
of what you want to see and if it's a
heist movie then you know there's a lot
been a lot of good heist movies
basically what it is is they had a bunch
of bunch of elements from a bunch of
different genres combined into the same
movie there's almost kind of like film
noir going on in it to where it's almost
almost trying to be Blade Runner one at
certain times when it comes with the
pacings and edit the Edit is very very
long how long do you think this movie
was I don't know [ __ ] man I could edit
this down into an into a really
adventurous 45 minutes and I think it
was about an hour and a half two and a
half hours this movie I bet you it
seemed like it was dragging when it did
have action it was okay when stuff did
happen it was okay but a lot of it is
nothing's happening it's just people
talking and you know we had that in the
50s where it was a whole movies of
people's in offices talking and to me
that's what this was you know I mean I'm
when I come to a movie I want to kind of
be entertained and when you think about
it all those little conversations and
all those little build ups and all that
carrot and all that was for nothing
I from my point of view I didn't need to
know any of that well no not really cuz
it all kind of played into the story I
didn't care about the story that's why
that's another factor you got I mean I
wanted to see the heist but then when
the heist happened it wasn't a very
impressive highest anyways so why did I
watch this at boring descent you know
from my point of very boring but you
know each to his own I should note that
like like I said the theater was fall
yeah old people you guys that you feel
they were right casters one of them had
been in a wheelchair like so the you
know she's kind of like they real they
ate the whole function his sewer it was
like a big plastic bag it had like chips
and I think yeah sandwich they must have
[ __ ] snuck in they snuck in so much
food and they were [ __ ] like they
were like every 10 minutes are opening a
new [ __ ] plastic package I was
getting ready to reach over there and
take her shake because her husband
couldn't stop me he's in a wheelchair
okay so the movie was the quality was
good the acting was everything it was
pretty good I mean you know everything
about the movie was good except the
story for me it's just very slow very
kind of boring I would I would I would
never sit to this again just sorry but
you know some people might like it
that's just my opinion just don't go
into it thinking that it's gonna be like
a fast pace yeah it's like a drama that
has like heist elements to it or like
criminal elements to it you know what I
mean it's not like a shoot-'em-up or
anything like that yeah
laughs it what you're saying
[ __ ] happens rarely I'm going here but
if I'm gonna see a crime flick that's
what you're waiting that's kind of like
well like I said so don't go thinking
that it's gonna do it like that it's
more like it's like a drama mostly right
there's but it has crime elements it our
swords daggers raw deal was better than
this
I don't read yeah it's pretty it's one
of the worst of the RDX okay I gotta go
we gotta go
what the [ __ ] that's not the stop button
you
okay we're back at it again over DMC
we've got done seeing Cree - yeah
specialist alone all-star cast actually
you know and his name Dolph Lundgren
comes back in it I'm gonna we're not
gonna spoil anything of course there's a
couple of cameos from some characters
that will kind of blow your mind
characters from bass yeah of course I've
seen I've seen all the the Rocky movies
and I saw create one also and with this
one I think I have to say that this may
have been the entire the best movie of
the entire series that's a bold
statement yeah because there's a lot of
new elements and just the music and and
the story the way the way it's done now
of course no rocky isn't the main
central figure of course and this one
you know but man you know Rocky one is a
is a very tough movie it's classic you
know to beat daddies but rocky one is an
older movie you know so it is a classic
this one I think stands right there with
it yeah I mean I definitely like I liked
this easily as much as the first rocky
and I liked it better than the first
Creed I really liked it too but I think
this one is much much better
honestly like because the stakes will
much higher yeah
or you're a lot more like emotionally
invested yeah even in the villains
you're kind of invested in the Isle Ike
that they didn't you make him like just
a straight-up villain like they gave him
a little bit of depth and stuff as well
yeah and it was kind of subtle the way
it was done yeah which I really liked
you know there wasn't a lot of talking
in between them there's only a couple
scenes where they were talking here but
I kind of liked that element that they
added to it they didn't just make him
like this best bad guy I would dead I
would definitely recommend it though
it's good and after seeing this and
they'll tell you what really makes you
look forward to the new rocky house TV
the new Rambo that's coming because I
think it's later on this year or maybe
next year I don't know but I think I
think it might be done yeah yeah I saw
some me some some like little shots from
it so that they're at least working on
it now but it's not gonna be long I
don't think it might be at the end of
the year but Stallone probably looks
better now than he did 10 years ago
he looks pretty good his face and
everything like and what was it that
last Rambo movie that he did you know
his face kinda little funny but he looks
good now yeah yeah so it really makes
you look forward to the next Rambo but
yeah he was like I mean I knew this was
gonna be good because the first Creed
was very good but this really like blew
my expectations everyone's like wait
yeah it's better I was expecting it it's
way better than the first one yeah and
you know like you said I think it's
easily easily as good as a rocky one
yeah alright guys see you mom
[Music]